>> CNN HAS OBTAINED A UKRAINIAN
MILITARY DOCUMENT THAT OUTLINES
THREAT POSED BY THE RUSSIAN
MERCENARY GROUP WAGNER.
IT VIVIDLY DESCRIBES THE
BRUTALITY OF THE PRIVATE
MILITARY FORCE.
EXPLAINS HOW EFFECTIVE THE
METHODS HAVE BEEN IN EASTERN
UKRAINE.
CNN'S FRED PLEITGEN HAS MORE ON
THIS AND A WARNING THAT HIS
REPORT CONTAINS GRAPHIC IMAGES
AND LANGUAGE.
[SPEAKING NON-ENGLISH]
[SOUND OF GUNFIRE]
>> AS RUSSIA'S INVASION OF
UKRAINE FALTERS, THERE IS ONE
GROUP THAT IS HAVING SOME
SUCCESS ON THE BATTLEFIELD.
THE BRUTALLY AFFECTIVE WAGNER
PRIVATE MILITARY COMPANY, LED
BY PUTIN ALLIES, YEVGENY
PRIGOZHIN.
[SPEAKING NON-ENGLISH]
>> TRANSLATOR: WHY ARE WE
EFFECTIVE, AND WHERE DOES THIS
EFFECTIVELY COME FROM? WE ASK.
FIRST, WE HAVE BEEN FIGHTING
FOR MANY YEARS.
PROBABLY, WE ARE THE MOST
EXPERIENCED ARMY IN THE WORLD
TODAY.
AND, UKRAINE'S LEADERSHIP IS
ALARMED BY WAGNER SUCCESS.
CNN HAS EXCLUSIVELY OBTAINED A
MILITARY DOCUMENT, OUTLINING
KYIV'S ASSESSMENT OF THE GROUP.
>> THERE ARE ALSO PURELY
MILITARY REASONS FOR WAGNER'S
EFFECTIVENESS TO DOCUMENT, IT
SAYS.
AS THE COMMAND STRUCTURE AND
TACTICS CURRENTLY EMPLOYED ARE
THE EARLY ONES THAT ARE
EFFECTIVE FOR THE POORLY
TRAINED MOBILIZED TROOPS THAT
MAKE UP THE MAJORITY OF RUSSIAN
GROUND FORCES.
>> UKRAINE'S MILITARY FILMED
THIS VIDEO SHOWING WAGNER'S
ASSAULT TACTICS USING WAVES OF
FIGHTERS TRYING TO OVERWHELM
AND ENCIRCLE EIGHT UKRAINIAN
POSITION.
THE TASKS ARE SAID TO BE AS
PRIMITIVE AS POSSIBLE TO
ACHIEVE THE GOAL MANY ASSAULT
GROUPS ARE DEPLOYED AND ATTACKS
CAN BE CARRIED OUT FOR A LONG
PERIOD OF TIME WITHOUT REGARD
TO LOSSES.
THE DOCUMENT SAYS.
[SOUND OF ARTILLERY]
THE FIRST WAVES ARE OFTEN
CONVICTS.
EVENTUALLY USED AS CANNON
FALLS.
THE DEATH OF THOUSANDS OF
WAGNER SOLDIERS, DO NOT MATTER
TO RUSSIAN SOCIETY, THE
MILITARY DOCUMENT EXERTS AND
UNAUTHORIZED WITHDRAWAL OF A
TEAM WITHOUT BEING WINDED IS
PUNISHABLE BY EXECUTION ON THE
SPOT.
YEVGENY PRIGOZHIN MAKES NO
SECRET OF THE FACT THAT LOSSES
DON'T MATTER TO HIM.
HE RECENTLY, VISITED A BUILDING
WHERE THE BODIES OF THE FALLEN
WERE KEPT.
[SPEAKING NON-ENGLISH]
THEIR CONTRACTS HAVE ENDED,
THEY'RE GOING HOME, HE SAYS.
BUT PRIGOZHIN ALSO CLAIMS TO
RESPECT THE UKRAINIANS
DEFENDING AGAINST HIS
MERCENARIES, SAYING, THEY'RE
FIGHTING WITH VALOR.
[SPEAKING NON-ENGLISH]
>> TRANSLATOR: YOU NEED TO BE
MORE CAREFUL TO SEND THEM OFF
IN A DIGNIFIED MANNER, HE SAYS,
WHILE RECENTLY OVERSEEING AN
EXCHANGE OF BODIES BETWEEN
WAGNER AND THE UKRAINIAN ARMY.
[SPEAKING NON-ENGLISH]
INTERNALLY, THOUGH, IT'S A
BRUTAL REGIME.
-- OR SOCIAL MEDIA CHANNEL
RECENTLY POSTED A VIDEO OF
MERCENARIES USING A
SLEDGEHAMMER TO KILL A FORMER
COMRADE WHO ALLEGEDLY DEFECTED
AND CRITICIZE THE GROUP.
THE WORD ASSAULT ON THE
BATTLEFIELD TO.
UKRAINIAN INTELLIGENCE
INTERCEPTED THIS CALL, WHICH
CNN CANNOT INDEPENDENTLY VERIFY
OF A RUSSIAN SOLDIER TALKING TO
A FRIEND ABOUT WAGNER.
[SPEAKING NON-ENGLISH]
[BLEEP] [BLEEP]
[BLEEP] [SPEAKING NON-ENGLISH]
[SOUND OF ARTILLERY]
>> STILL WAGNER'S MORALE SEEMS
HIGH, THE UKRAINIANS SAY.
AND, THE FIGHTERS ARE OFTEN
BETTER EQUIPPED THAN RUSSIA'S
REGULAR FORCES, THANKS TO WHAT
THE UKRAINIANS CLAIM IS U.S.
MADE TECHNOLOGY.
IN CONTRAST TO THE RUSSIAN
ARMED FORCES, WAGNER'S MAIN --
ARE AMERICAN MADE RADIO
STATIONS AND MOTOROLA WALKIE
TALKIE'S, THE UKRAINIAN
DOCUMENTS.
AS CNN DID REACH OUT TO
MOTOROLA FOR A STATEMENT AND
THEY HAD SAID THAT, SHORTLY
AFTER RUSSIA INVADED UKRAINE,
THAT THEY STOPPED ALL THEIR
SALES TO BOTH RUSSIA AND TO
BELARUS AND CLOSED THEIR
OPERATIONS THERE.
MEANWHILE, THOSE DOCUMENTS FROM
THE UKRAINIAN MILITARY, THERE
IS A LOT OF FASCINATING THINGS
IN THERE.
FOR EXAMPLE, THE UKRAINIANS SAY
THAT DESPITE THE INFIGHTING
THAT YOU SEE BETWEEN THE
RUSSIAN DEFENSE MINISTRY AND
WAGNER, SPECIFICALLY OF YEVGENY
PRIGOZHIN, THE RUSSIAN MILITARY
IS NOW RECOMMENDING SOME OF
THOSE BRUTAL ASSAULT TACTICS
FROM WAGNER FROM RUSSIAN
REGULAR FORCES AS WELL.
FRED PLEITGEN, CNN, KYIV.